[Musique]
et Gérard longa nous accompagne donc
pendant cette première demi-heure
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
monsieur Longuet vous êtes élu de la
Meuse bon du groupe les républicains et
vous allez quitter le Sénat dans les
prochains jours après 22 ans de mandat
on va revenir évidemment sur vos années
Sénat oui sur vos années sur le plan
local puisque vous avez été élu de
Lorraine pendant de nombreuses années
mais d'abord un mot de l'actualité on
l'a vu l'actualité du côté de
l'empedouza ou des milliers de migrants
ont débarqué ces derniers jours est-ce
que la France doit se montrer solidaire
avec l'Italie et en accueillir une
partie la France doit surtout rappeler
l'Europe à ses responsabilités il est
totalement
invraisemblable que Madame
découvre aujourd'hui le problème c'est
le sentiment qu'elle donne ça fait
plusieurs années qu'elle est en charge
la présidence ça fait des hélas
plusieurs années décennies que nous
avons avec Lampedusa un terrain
d'atterrissage pour des professionnels
de l'immigration forcée et qui partent
un peu de Tunisie beaucoup de Libye et à
part la responsabilité de la solidarité
européenne est un devoir mais la
responsabilité européenne la
responsabilité de la commission la
responsabilité du Conseil des ministres
de l'Europe et directement engagé cette
affaire est affaire connu depuis
longtemps et manifestement en amont sur
des des transports qui ne sont pas
spontanés tout est organisé depuis le
pays d'origine des pays d'origine qui ne
sont pas heureusement et là heureusement
qui ne sont pas tous en situation de
guerre civile comme le Soudan par
exemple ou à un moment la Somalie nous
avons des pays qui se sentent très bien
le Mali le
la Centrafrique le Niger et qui nous
envoie d'une façon professionnelle
j'insiste n'a pas un côté spontané c'est
une organisation professionnelle avec
des gens qui trouvent leur intérêt et
qui gagnent de l'argent en exploitant
ces malheureux dans les transports sont
financés par la solidarité villageoise
locale nous avons un besoin absolu en
Europe c'est d'avoir une attitude
offensive vis-à-vis mais c'est des pays
qui se consultent
les migrants qui viennent de pays qui ne
sont pas en guerre vous les renvoyer
chez eux c'est ça totalement en tous les
cas les empêche de partir parce que nous
ne pouvons pas apporter de solutions en
revanche nous pouvons les investir sur
place investir sur la formation investir
ceux qui sont là ça va être assez
difficile c'est pour ça que c'est en
amont et c'est en mai après tout l'aide
matérielle a existé et peut-être les
aider à refaire leur vie localement en
tous les cas il n'est pas possible de
prétendre découvrir le problème alors
que ça fait plus de 10 ans que Lampedusa
est une terre d'atterrissage donc ça
veut dire que les milliers de migrants
qui ont débarqué ces derniers jours la
France doit en accueillir plusieurs la
France en accueillera c'est une évidence
la France en Académia pas solidarité de
l'Italie mais je crois qu'il faut être
deux noms de nom accueillir en
contrepartie de mesures européennes
collectives qui tarde à venir est-ce que
l'Europe d'ailleurs l'Union européenne
est très ambiguë et la Commission est
très ambiguë nous avions un commissaire
nous avions un responsable français qui
s'occupait de ces questions il a été
viré comme un malpropre parce qu'il
justement il mettait en garde les pays
européens sur l'absence de politique aux
frontières est-ce que c'est aussi
l'avenir de l'Europe qui se joue c'est
ce que disait hier Georgia Meloni est-ce
que l'Europe peut périr si elle ne
résout pas cette crise migratoire si
elle ne manifeste pas de solidarité elle
sera en effet remise en question ce sera
du chacun pour soi comme la Hongrie on a
donné l'image
on va revenir sur vous maintenant Gérard
Longuet puisque vous allez quitter le
Sénat dans quelques jours on va revenir
sur vos années Sénats dans quelques
instants mais d'abord on va aller chez
vous en Lorraine où on retrouve Frédéric
Blancard bonjour merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous Frédéric reporter régional à
l'Est Républicain et vous souhaitez
revenir vous sur le parcours de Gérard
Longuet Gérard Lanka évidemment
dissociable de la Meuse
tout à fait bonjour bonjour à vous
bonjour monsieur le ministre oui
personnalité
incontournable de la Meuse personnalité
politique incontournable 45 ans de vie
politique en Meuse on va rappeler
pêle-mêle son élection de députés en
1978 en
1986-93 au Conseil Général de la Meuse
pour la première fois en 1979 dans le
canton de seuil d'Argonne puis dans le
canton de fresnes-en-wavre il a été même
je crois vice-président du Conseil
Général de la Meuse il a été aussi
conseillé régional de Lorraine président
du conseil régional entre 92 et 2004
sénateur vous l'avez rappelé pendant 22
ans il a été aussi trois fois ministre
dans deux gouvernements de cohabitation
sous Jacques Chirac le gouvernement
Jacques Chirac et le gouvernement
Balladur ministre des postes et des
télécommunications pardon puis ministre
de l'Industrie des postes
télécommunications extérieur et plus
récemment sous le gouvernement Fillon
ministre de la Défense et les anciens
combattants entre 2011 et 2012
on peut dire que Gérard Longuet en Meuse
fait partie du paysage politique fait
partie des meubles peu de gens
d'ailleurs il est assez proche de de son
électorat peu de gens l'appel monsieur
le ministre comme le veut le voudrait
l'usage sauf dans les cérémonies
officielles c'est souvent Gérard ou
monsieur il y a une certaine proximité
il a marqué le territoire et puis on
peut rappeler que avec Raymond Poincaré
André Maginot et Louis Jacquinot c'est
le seul politique me vient avoir eu une
envergure nationale et le seul sous la
5e République
fait aussi
fonction de sage il a une bonne vision
de la politique nationale et meusienne
et celui que les politiques consultent
il a aussi la denture après des souvent
des élections perdues et c'est une forme
de pragmatique il a été aussi élu de la
Meuse
de pardon qu'il était qu'il est élu d'un
département essentiellement agricoles
très très peu industrialisés et qui perd
des habitants mais mais c'est un
département de mémoire et ça c'est
extrêmement important
avec la ville de Verdun par exemple qui
est connu en France et à l'étranger
justement vous avez une question une
question sur le parcours et la place que
tient la Meuse dans le parcours Gérard
Longuet tout à fait moi je souhaiterais
lui demander quelle place tient
justement la Meuse dans votre carrière
politique essentielle
essentiel parce que le département m'a
permis d'être élu à 32 ans députés et
j'ai pu ainsi
participer à toute une génération
libérale qui a quand même profondément
modifié notre pays
pense notamment avec la Madeleine
François Léotard mais surtout avec
balade Édouard Balladur on a contribué à
changer ce pays je pensais d'ailleurs en
venant que Public Sénat n'existe que
parce que la loi de 86 sur l'audiovisuel
a libéré l'audiovisuel comme d'ailleurs
les autres chaînes d'information donc
j'appartiens à une équipe qui n'a pas
exercé le pouvoir principalement mais
qui a contribué à déréguler les télécoms
je les fais c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
qu'aujourd'hui les télécoms c'est une
activité totalement privée quand je l'ai
découverte en 86 c'était une activité
totalement d'État j'ai eu la chance de
pouvoir m'impliquer sur des projets
industriels notamment sur l'énergie
nucléaire en attaquant un maillon
extrêmement particulier difficile qui
est le maillon du traitement des déchets
nucléaires et si aujourd'hui on peut
dans le cadre de la transition
énergétique des carbonées avec le
nucléaire si bien parce que la Meuse et
la Haute-Marne d'ailleurs ont accepté de
de participer au traitement des déchets
à forte activité donc en me retournant
je me dis que finalement j'étais assez
utile à un certain nombre de sujets
c'est vrai que j'ai parfois la denture
et le goût des formules mais le travail
de long terme il y a un fil conducteur
c'est la décentralisation avec
Jean-Pierre Raffarin on a quand même
l'air de rien quand j'étais président de
l'Association des régions de France fait
passer cent mille fonctionnaires de
l'État vers les collectivités locales
département et région aucun n'a contesté
ce changement parce que la
décentralisation en général réussie est
plait aux Français donc voilà je me
retourne j'ai pas encore le temps des
bilans j'ai pas eu le l'occasion
d'écrire quoi que ce soit mais vous
m'invitez ce matin j'ai réfléchi un
petit peu il y a des choses utiles qui
ont été faites
oui de quoi êtes-vous le plus fier en
Meuse et quel est votre plus grand
regret alors mon plus grand regret c'est
de ne pas avoir vu
que l'industrie changeait et qu'il y
avait une concentration
sur les grandes unités sur les bassins
d'activités tertiaires c'est-à-dire sur
les métropoles et vous avez dit tout à
l'heure la mesure rurale oui elle est
rurale mais elle a toujours été
industrielle aussi les vallées étaient
dévalées métallurgiques le travail du
bois le travail de l'acier et ça ça
c'est un petit peu essoufflé ce dont je
suis fier c'est quelques réussites
industrielles par exemple la Smart en
Lorraine par exemple et évolue qui est
le un grand fournisseur de de bus et
d'autocars aligné-en-barrois donc il y a
un jalon pratique de safran à Commercy
la reconversion de l'activité militaire
par des activités civiles qui qui
aujourd'hui la porte de la richesse
locale bon je crois que le il faut
prendre le temps d'écrire un bilan il
sera pas il sera je crois positif merci
Frédéric merci le plus ce dont je suis
le plus fier c'est d'avoir avec André
rossino et Madame trottemann rossino
maire de Nancy madame trotmann maire de
Strasbourg
permis la mise en oeuvre du tgvs tout le
monde le voulait et personne le faisait
et à trois avec la région et les deux
grandes villes on a réussi à faire
quelque chose de bien d'ailleurs je
l'emprunte trois fois par semaine donc
quatre fois parce que je reviens
se cacher de Verdun expo c'est à la Une
de l'Est Républicain dans la Meuse ce
matin merci beaucoup Frédéric Blancard
d'avoir été avec nous on va continuer à
parler de vous Gérard Longuet à faire
votre bilan on va plutôt s'intéresser à
vos années Sénat maintenant Alex Pusa
s'est plongé dans vos archives il arrive
[Musique]
bonjour Alex bonjour Oriane bonjour
45 ans de vie politique et oui 45 ans de
vie politique 22 ans au Sénat alors de
vos années à l'hôtel assemblée générale
Longuet on peut retenir que vous avez
été le président du groupe
UMP puis vous avez également présidé
l'Office parlementaire d'évaluation des
choix scientifiques et technologiques et
qui est un organe commun au Sénat et à
l'Assemblée nationale et puis vous avez
aussi été rapporteur du budget de
l'enseignement scolaire pendant
plusieurs années ce qui fait que vous
avez beaucoup travaillé sur la question
de l'école Gérard Longuet qu'est-ce que
vous retenez de vos années Sénat
le plaisir de travailler avec des gens
qui connaissent les sujets et quel que
soit leur position politique et avec
lesquels on peut débattre à ses
utilements j'ai été député élu quatre
fois aussi avec le précédent
c'est-à-dire au XXème siècle mais je me
suis rendu compte que ma vie politique
est plus longue au 21e qu'au 20e et le
20e je l'ai fait avec le Sénat donc là
satisfaction c'est de pouvoir débattes
je vois par exemple sur le fils
parlementaire d'évaluation nous avons
toujours des rapporteurs sénateurs et
députés avec des gens qui peuvent avoir
des convictions différentes et on arrive
à rapprocher les points de vue y compris
sur des sujets extrêmement sensibles
comme la bioéthique comme la génétique
comme l'énergie et le nucléaire on
arrive à voir une présentation d'un
d'une situation d'une façon
partagée par des gens qui peuvent avoir
sur le fond des points de vue différents
donc selon vous le travaillez plus
constructif à la Haute Assemblée
nationale des positions politiques
à l'Assemblée j'ai été député j'ai été
ministre face à l'Assemblée c'est le
clivage politique qui l'emporte vous
êtes pour le Président vous applaudissez
vous êtes contre le président vous
critiquez ici on a une du recul alors
j'ai rallongé dans ce portrait on va
parler d'une facette de votre caractère
le parler vrai vous faites rarement dans
la langue de bois et certains se
souviennent de vos propos sur le rapport
des Français au travail
ce qui compte le plus c'est la
motivation professionnelle nous avons
des Français qui ont des poils dans la
main il faut le savoir c'est à dire qui
c'est trop dur c'est trop loin c'est pas
ce que je veux vous comprenez moi
j'étais formé pour faire du théâtre et
on me propose de faire du commerce non
c'est une vérité
est-ce que vous le regrettez
il m'a pas toujours rendu service mais
c'est inhérent mon personnage si vous
voulez moi je fais de la politique parce
que j'ai des convictions et la première
conviction par exemple c'est qu'en effet
en matière économique il faut accepter
le travail tel qu'il se présente comme
dirait le président Macron et j'ai
l'impression d'être un prédécesseur en
quelque sorte il suffit parfois de
traverser la rue pour trouver quelque
chose mais il faut accepter de ne pas
faire exactement ce que l'on rêvait de
faire mais est-ce que cette réflexion ça
ne dispense pas d'une autre réflexion
sur l'attractivité de certains métiers
qui doivent aussi
des formules
audiovisuel pardonnez-moi on n'a pas
beaucoup de temps et ce matin non plus
ne permet pas de travailler dans la
nuance moi ce que je voulais l'exprimer
on me posait la question la question
c'était que semblait qu'il y avait en
France un chômage incompressible donc je
réponds à la question du chômage
incompressible on est à aujourd'hui on
est à un peu plus de 7% de chômeurs il y
a des demandes des entreprises il y a
des offres de la part des entreprises
qui ne sont pas satisfaites l'un des
problèmes majeurs chez partout en France
c'est que les gens ne trouvent pas de
travailleurs pour remplir des postes et
pourtant il y a 7 % de chômeurs il faut
donc se poser la question alors
évidemment dans l'audiovisuel on sait
pas un cours d'agrégation de sciences
économiques où on a trois heures pour
défendre un sujet il faut le faire en 30
secondes en 30 secondes et parfois un
peu schématique je suis d'accord alors
j'ai rallongé on va évoquer un moment un
petit peu douloureux de votre carrière
politique les affaires judiciaires qui
vous ont mis en cause notamment sur le
financement de votre partie ou de votre
villa à Saint-Tropez au final vous avez
obtenu dans ces affaires 5 relax et un
non-lieu mais elle vous ont plutôt coûté
cher politiquement notamment quand vous
avez dû démissionner de votre poste de
ministre on va regarder un extrait vous
avez tout dit vous défendre mon honneur
pour faire respecter
ce que je suis
un citoyen parmi d'autres
se défendant
selon des règles fondées sur la
présomption d'innocence
quelles leçons genre vous tirez de ces
épreuves
la justice est longue et lente et j'ai
eu gain de cause très rapidement sur des
sujets personnels vous les avez évoqués
j'ai eu une cause en un an deux ans
trois ans sur le financement du parti
politique dont j'avais la responsabilité
alors qu'il n'existait aucune loi dans
la période concernée ce qui est quand
même important de savoir j'ai mis
presque 15 ans et pendant 15 ans j'ai
été paralysé j'ai presque envie de dire
tant mieux parce que ça m'a permis
d'exercer des responsabilités régionales
à la présidence de la région lorraine
avec le soutien de toutes les formations
du Conseil Régional de Lorraine et j'ai
fait des choses sérieuses je vais faire
une confidence je n'aime pas le régime
présidentiel et finalement
sauf si la personnalité me convient je
n'ai pas le goût de m'aligner
bon je sers loyalement ceux qui me
demandent mais je ne cours pas après un
chef pour me protéger derrière lui et
donc finalement en étant en retrait
c'était pas forcément malheureux je
voudrais remercier Nicolas Sarkozy parce
que il m'a nommé ministre la défense dès
que j'ai obtenu mon dernier non lieu il
me l'avait dit il m'avait dit mais j'ai
capable mais tant que tu mises en examen
je ne peux rien faire le jour où j'ai
cessé de porter cette tunique de Nexus
judiciaire il m'a nommé au ministère de
la Défense
je crois où j'ai été très heureux à
titre personnel et je crois que les
militaires ne s'en sont pas plaints
ils sont mises en examen la société je
suis libéral je suis pour la libre
expression et j'ai en effet avec
d'autres contribué à déréguliers je
l'évoquais tout à l'heure l'audiovisuel
la contrepartie et les réseaux sociaux
le numérique tout ça c'est une même un
courant libéral de transparence absolue
cette transparence est nouveau en France
vingtaine d'années elle a des
contreparties la contrepartie c'est que
il faut ne pas trop prêter à la critique
le fait que le magistrat vous mettre en
examen ça vous expose et ça expose votre
famille politique et donc par je dirais
par respect du citoyen et pour le calme
de la vie politique il faut prendre
cette règle elle est plus suivie
l'avocat est un avocat connu dont les
relations avec les magistrats ne sont
pas forcément cordiales alors qu'il a
fait un travail très convenable comme
garde des sceaux c'est vrai que cette
situation on voit un ministre patient en
cours de Jésus de la République sur les
affaires qui ne concerne pas son
ministère je dois dire que ça contribue
à dégrader l'image de la politique non
pas du fait de Dupont-Moretti mais de
cette obligation de transparence vous
savez il n'y a pas de grand homme pour
son Valais dit-on et avec la
transparence absolue tout vous excès de
vitesse votre coup de gueule
le fait que vous oubliez de payer une
facture tout ça devient des événements
je trouve qu'on arrange d'ailleurs
j'observe aujourd'hui que la qualité des
candidats à la vie politique mais
peut-être pas aussi forte qu'elle a été
par le passé alors j'ai rallongé on peut
dire que vous avez un rapport compliqué
en tout cas tranché avec la guerre
d'Algérie et la décolonisation et en
2012 l'Algérie demande à la France une
reconnaissance des crimes du
colonialisme et sur le plateau de Public
Sénat à ce moment-là alors que
l'émission est terminée alors que
l'émission est terminée je vais vous
dire des choses une chose alors juste
pour préciser
juste pour préciser un téléspectateurs
vous faites le geste d'un bras d'honneur
à cette demande de reconnaissance et
effectivement c'est sur le générique de
fin le contexte le contexte si vous
faites une
nationale je vais vous dire Clémenceau
aurait été envoyé en correctionnel à peu
près tous les matins car tous les matins
il avait un mot spirituel or Clémenceau
a sauvé la France on était content de
l'avoir alors au-delà du geste je
voudrais qu'on revienne sur le fond car
vous l'avez fait car vous êtes contre
l'idée de repentance sur ce qui s'est
passé pendant la guerre d'Algérie et sur
ce sujet je voudrais qu'on écoute
130 années de présence
d'Algérie c'est très difficile et comme
ministre de la Défense j'ai autorisé une
exposition que le ministère des Affaires
étrangères ne voulait pas sur la la
France l'armée française en Algérie
pourquoi parce qu'il y a à prendre et à
laisser mais moi je suis pour la vérité
historique c'est-à-dire des espèces
comme ils se sont déroulés et justement
sur cette vérité historique et sur
l'idée de repentance on va écouter
l'historien Benjamin Stora il était sur
notre plateau vendredi et il parlait de
l'idée de repentance en France
moi je veux bien qu'on dénonce la
repentance et encore faut-il qu'elle
existe j'aime bien à ma connaissance il
n'y a pas tous les matins des discours
d'hommes politiques français qui
s'excuse ou qui non il y a pas ça il y a
au contraire une situation où on
continue d'avancer
sur un sur un mode qui est celui de la
fin de cette histoire des colonies
depuis très longtemps or c'est pas vrai
ce qu'on a fermé trop vite la page de
cette histoire des colonies on a oublié
que 800 000 Français ont dû toujours au
lendemain choisir entre la valise et le
cercueil on a oublié que sans doute 100
musulmans Français d'Algérie ont payé de
leur vie ou de leur liberté leur
engagement pour la France la France a
tourné la page n'a pas voulu savoir quel
était la souffrance ceux qui ont perdu
l'Algérie qui ont qui ont perdu leur vie
en Algérie et la raison de mon
engagement initial c'est en effet cela
après sur la colonisation et sur la
présence française en Algérie en
débattre tout au long et je suis prêt à
reconnaître et bien que nous avons
dépensé beaucoup d'énergie beaucoup
d'efforts sans savoir exactement où nous
allions et le vrai problème de la France
en Algérie c'est qu'elle y est elle est
avec Charles X en 1830 et bugeaux et
seul peut-être Napoléon III sur sur
l'empire arabe avait imaginé une
solution il faut quand même savoir que
si les s'il est musulmans en Algérie
n'avaient pas la nationalité française
c'est parce que la nationalité
impliquait d'abandonner la charia et
donc la France a respecté l'islam en
Algérie justement vous parlez de votre
engagement politique initial
c'est-à-dire à l'extrême droite vous
avez vous avez été membre du mouvement
Occident est-ce que vous le regrettez au
final dans le contexte de l'époque je
l'explique mais si vous avez une soirée
à me consacrer je pourrais vous la
consacrer un dernier mot Gérard Longuet
au moment où vous quittez le Sénat on
imagine que vous allez garder un œil sur
la politique est-ce que vous êtes
inquiet sur l'avenir de votre partition
l'avenir des républicains de la France
parce que je trouve que nous sommes dans
une situation de déclin démographique
il y a 100 000 enfants de moins qui
naissent chaque année il y en avait 820
000 en
2012 10 ans après il y en a 720000 la
France vieillit et un pays qui
vieillissent un pays qui ne croit plus
en lui qui n'a pas confiance dans son
avenir et qui manque de de combativité
moi je souhaite une société française
extrêmement vivante avec sans doute des
oppositions avec des points de vue
différents mais avec de la création avec
de l'énergie et aujourd'hui cette
énergie semble disparaître merci Jérôme
uet mais le sén